[Music]
welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast in this episode Greg shares a
coaching tip on using exaggerated cues
for lifting technique then we discussed
a ton of new studies that came out this
month topics include fat free mass index
dietary nitrate caffeine sleep grape
kool-aid and more then we have an
interview with dr. Brad dieter who tells
us about research on artificial
sweeteners processed foods and body fat
setpoints thanks for listening and enjoy
the episode welcome back to the stronger
by science podcast this is your host
eric Trexler I'm joined by my temporary
guest host Greg knuckles thank you for
having me back home of course
yeah so when you think stronger by
science you probably think lil yachty
lil Uzi vert a little pump to Keshe 6:9
because we are in good company we are
now available on soundcloud yeah we we
saw how many of the truly defining
artists of our generation got their
start on that platform a fair amount of
our listeners had requested that we get
on soundcloud were still on virtually
every podcast app out there plus YouTube
and Spotify but fair amount of people
wanted SoundCloud so we are now joining
the greats on SoundCloud to try to take
over the platform absolutely we took
over all the others and we got one more
kind of in our crosshairs here
yes sir okay so to start the episode
Greg you got some feats of strength this
week yeah so there haven't been that
many huge meets recently so this will be
shorter than normal
I feel like feats of strength is almost
just becoming the Julius Maddox watch we
talked about him breaking the American
record with a 723 bench in our last
episode more recently he just posted on
Instagram a set doing 610 for eight with
it was kind of paused
they were paused but they were pauses
that may not count in competition if
that makes sense
that is the heaviest set kind of in that
that that's the most reps I've ever seen
anyone do with in excess of 600 pounds
Eric Spoto did six oh five or eight
touch-and-go back in the day
and by back in the day I mean like three
years ago and Kirill Sara czev I believe
he did somewhere in the neighborhood of
six hundred four five super controlled
super solid just like every other rep
Sara Jeff has ever done which he may
have been able to push that out to eight
but he only did five but man anything
over six hundred is incredibly
impressive that video of Julie cymatics
hitting 610 four eight is wild but the
reason I'm putting it on this list is I
recommend you searching it out on
Instagram because the guy taking the
video of it is equal parts hilarious and
adorable because I don't think he
realized that he was going for eight so
after like rep three or four he just
starts freaking out he said and I quote
what the [ __ ] whoa bro excuse me but
very very excitedly fair he's not wrong
no no I mean if if you happened upon
someone with six hundred loaded on the
bar to bench and you have no idea that
they're going to go for a set of eight
after number three you would probably be
freaking out too but just just the the
pure joy of it of of the camera person
really makes the video worth the watch
you had you had other feats of strength
yeah I do want to mention though it's
absolutely bonkers that he keeps showing
up week after week like when you're
already that good you're not supposed to
keep getting this much better well so I
think I think it illustrates the
principle of the people who are the best
at anything getting a dish a
disproportionate amount of the attention
yeah because dude's been strong for a
long time it was just Spoto was still
competing and then Sarah czev was still
competing I haven't seen anything out of
either of them in a long time I think
Spoto is still still training but maybe
coming back from injury and
I don't even know that Sarah Chavez
powerlifting anymore the rare training
videos of him that do pop up
he doesn't seem anywhere close to top
shape he's um he's involved in that
Russian slap fighting League in some way
shape or form I've seen that there was a
video there was a video maybe two or
three weeks ago that everyone I know
sent to me where one of the Russian slap
fighters did look in alarming amount
like me with long hair so if you sent me
that just know you weren't the only one
a lot of other people saw that
resemblance but Sarah czev I guess was
like the referee for that so I think you
know I think he's just out there living
his best life but yeah anyway so what I
was saying is Julius Maddox has been one
of the five or ten best ventures in the
world for a long time and I think people
just didn't know about him because
unless you're the best in the world or
someone who's like number two and looks
like you're coming for the person who's
currently the best in the world a lot of
people just fly under the radar and I
think I I mean I would say at this point
he's absolutely the best the best raw
super heavyweight venture currently
competing and so I think until he took
the crown like people just weren't
weren't paying attention to him but I
mean now that he it now that he is dudes
crazy impressive he he took an attempt
that would have broken Sarah cheves
record at his last meet and it looked
pretty close
like I think he'll have that record in
the next six months to a year alright
and so we got some other ones this week
as well right yeah Ashton Ruska competed
I believe this past weekend so Ashton
typically competes at 93 kilos or 205
pounds he missed weight at this most
recent meter maybe he just didn't cut
weight I'm not sure which it wasn't a
huge meat like Nationals or worlds or
anything like that so he may have just
not cut but he weighed in at 208
or what would that be like ninety four
and a half kilos so barely over the 93
limit so he competed at 105 and as
basically as light of a 105 as one could
possibly be
he set the unofficial IPF world record
breaking we're Vicki's recent record the
reason I say unofficial is in the IPF
you can only set world records at meats
with enough international level judges
which I believe is generally only
national and world meets so like I said
this wasn't NAT and maybe you can at the
Arnold I'm not sure about that but but I
think you can be a so this was just a
state meet so he unofficially broke the
record at 105 as the lightest 105 one
could possibly be totaled a nice smooth
900 kilos in the process that's nineteen
hundred and eighty four pound total via
705 squat 457 bench and 821 deadlift
this I would consider probably the
second most impressive total of all time
at that general body weight so a few
years ago Jessie Norris totaled 2015 at
198 the weight classes were recently
changed so now the weight class
corresponding to the old 198 classes the
205 class but yeah Jessie's currently
the only person competing tested who's
gone over 2000 at around a 200 body
weight Ashton looks like he's he's very
close to doing so and like I said I mean
like we're Vicki is a incredibly good
power lifter in his own right and here's
a guy who weighs 25 pounds less just
competing a weight class up because he
didn't cut to his normal weight class
breaky setting an unofficial world
record there so that's that's also super
super impressive and then the last feat
of strength I had this week was tien-tao
and weightlifting he clean and jerked to
31 and 96
in kind of a tuneup meet for the
Olympics in 2020 I should note that in
Enzo to 31 and 96 is 509 pounds at 211
pounds I should note that the IWF
greeted their weight classes this past
year so weightlifting redoes their
weight classes pretty frequently similar
to what the IPF did and powerlifting
last year as well where I don't know if
they explicitly say this but the
understood reason for why they changed
their weight classes around from time to
time is basically when drug testing
improves they don't want people who
realistically probably are drug-free but
are having to beat more strenuous tests
than folks of prior generations they
don't want them to have to compete
against those prior world records which
were probably done under under less
rigorously tested circumstances so they
change the weight classes from time to
time so if there's a little bit of like
a world record reset basically yeah yeah
so with the old weight classes the the
world record was 233 at 94 so 2 kilos
heavier at a 2 kilo lighter body weight
by so Rab maratti from Iran but yeah
tien-tao coming very very close to that
old record of 233 there's probably gonna
be a lot of weightlifting records broken
in the next couple of years just because
of that weight class restructuring but
uh but yeah I mean 231 at 96
even if it is not quite as good as the
old record still crazy impressive yeah
now so for today's episode we wanted to
obviously we're gonna get to some
research later but we wanted to do a
little bit of the segment that we call
Coaches Corner
where we talk about some more practical
lifting related information and we were
chatting the other day about lifting
queues and you had mentioned a technique
that you've used in the past working
with athletes where you mentioned that
you give exaggerated cues in your
terminology was in both directions
yeah but what got us on that topic of
conversation is I seem to remember it
was either you or Greg Schultz one of
you two said that you tried something
that was like very very slightly
different
I believe with your squat and when he
looked at it on video you could barely
see a difference or couldn't see a
difference at all but it felt a ton
better what was that you were him I
think that was him okay
but yeah that's something that that's
something that a lot of lifters
experience and I think that I think a
lot of lifters and coaches may be a
little bit over-reliant on video
analysis like I think most lifters have
probably have probably experienced this
where you lift a weight it feels [ __ ]
terrible and then you look at it you
look at the lift on video and the video
looks pretty good or you know the the
opposite can occur as well like
something may look kind of sketchy on
video but feel pretty decent when you do
it or you make some sort of technique
correction and it feels a million times
better and then when you compare it to
old technique videos you're like you
know it's like that Pam from the office
mean corporate wants you to spot the
difference between these two things and
there's no difference except generally
in the meme it's two things that are
very different but yeah you get the
point ya know it's funny you bring that
up because you know one of my clients
that I work with online just this past
week and they're check-in sends me a
video of a lift and and they're like oh
my god you know squats this week just
felt like trash and I'm like well here
we go I open up the file it looked
pretty damn good and so it was one of
those things where on the video it
wasn't jumping out so then you have to
pry a little deeper and say didn't feel
good in what way like you know and then
you start prying with additional
questions but but anyway you're you kind
of went off on when we were talking
about this with Greg you went off on
like a little bit of a tangent about
this cueing technique you've used in the
past yeah so the III I think what
most coaches do when they queue people
is they're trying to queue someone to
put them in the right general position
which for someone who doesn't understand
a lift at all they're they're just
learning a lift that is a very very good
way to queue someone they don't know the
positions they're supposed to be in they
don't know what it's supposed to feel
like
so you queue them to get in generally
good positions to start developing
decent motor skills for queueing lifters
who know a lift pretty well already and
you're just trying to iron out a little
technique issue or you're like just
generally trying to get something to
feel better or to get rid of a bad habit
something I found that works really
really well is giving bad cues and what
I mean by bad cues is if they're doing
something wrong you cue them to do it
even wronger like they they know you're
not telling them oh no good technique is
actually just to do whatever you're
doing but do it even worse like if
someone's weight is shifting really far
forward on their feet when they squat
like if they feel their weight shifting
forward tell them squat with your weight
as far forward on your feet as possible
you're not telling them that's the way
you're supposed to squat you're just
cueing them to do that or the exact
opposite thing where if cue them in the
direction you want them to go but
overcorrect so if someone is say tucking
their elbows way too much on bench tell
them like hey try flaring your elbows as
much as possible the logic behind the
first one and there's actually research
to support this actually in Volume one
issue one of mass are very inaud
inaugural issue I reviewed a study by
Melanie's at all called the effect of
two different correction strategies on
snatch technique in weightlifting and
what they termed that first method of if
someone's making a mistake cue them to
overdo the mistake they turn to the
method of amplification of error and the
logic behind that is that
most people most people improve
technique partially by rep by repetition
but also through error identification
and correction and so if someone is
lifting in a way that's going to
decrease their performance your your
goal is to make them really see what
that is doing and so if they're only
messing something up a little bit by
getting them to fully lean into that
mistake that they're making that it's
not just telling them what the
consequences it's letting them feel it
under load and my under load I'm not
talking about doing one rep maxes with
intentionally jacked-up form I'm talking
you know submaximal stuff but if you
know if you lude load a significant
amount like say fifty sixty percent of
your max and have someone lifts with
intentionally suboptimal technique
exaggerated in such a way that they have
to feel the consequence of it then that
helps them realize both consciously and
subconsciously like oh here's what's
going wrong when I do this and now
here's what I can do to correct for it
and so it's it's letting their nervous
system kind of run that process of of
finding and correcting the error instead
of you as the coach saying like oh no
shift your weight back one more inch on
your foot like that's probably not gonna
do anything
yeah and that's that's a really good
point I actually didn't make the
connection between these two things but
I remember when I first started out
doing like in person strength coaching I
was working with young athletes and we I
was really adamant about teaching them
good squats good deadlifts and a lot of
the other coaches in the room would with
their athletes they be doing virtually
unloaded lifts for in my opinion for
inappropriately long periods of time I
mean it was just weeks and weeks of just
like no load whatsoever and I've always
felt the other way like I mean obviously
I'm not gonna take a novice and just say
you know let's load plate after plate on
but I wanted them to feel when they were
miss grooving I wanted them to feel when
they had a technical flaw and I felt
like there was kind of a certain
threshold of weight we we needed to be
above so they could actually experience
what their bad technique is doing to
them yeah exactly sense yeah so it's the
exact same logic but then when you apply
it to someone who does already know the
lifts you know they can obviously do the
lifts so just loading it probably isn't
gonna do much for you yeah if you wanted
if you have higher risk tolerance than I
do you could probably just have them do
rep maxes or max all the time and it
would accomplish the same basic thing
just because going to failure or doing
max load whatever errors you're making
that's going to amplify the effect but
this method of queuing into technical
mistakes someone is making can help you
accomplish the same thing but with with
a more moderate load and then the
opposite approach of basically over
correcting for for good technique so the
example I gave is if someone is like way
way over tucking their elbows you look
at their bench from the side their
elbows are two inches in front of the
bar telling them like flare your elbows
like touch super high on your chest that
could accomplish one of two things one
is they do actually do that they they
swing way back in the other direction
they flare their elbows a ton that
doesn't feel good either and then it's
like okay well let's gradually tuck your
elbows a little bit more a little bit
more a little bit more and then let them
feel for themselves like what's my happy
medium here so it's kind of like so
let's say it's it's kind of like a
rubber band
and the optimal tension for this rubber
band is slightly more slack than it
currently is so let's say like the
circumference of a rubber band when it's
just like sitting on your desk is 3
inches and ideal would be for it to be 3
and a half inches if you want it to get
to three and a half inches if you just
stretch it out to three and a half
inches and then let it go it's gonna
snap right back to three inches to put
some more slack in it you would need to
you know over stretch it
and then when you let it go now it maybe
a little bit slacker and get back to
three and a half inches and that's now
it's like normal tension kind of the
same thing so if you know if you want
someone like let's say someone's hips
are shooting way way back when they
squat instead of just saying like mmm
well they're shooting a little bit too
far back let's let's try to keep them
another inch under the bar that's not
gonna do anything so massively
overcorrected and say like you know I
don't want your hips to move forward or
back any at all I want you to shove them
as far forward as you can from the very
start of the movement well then when you
do start loading them more and their
hips to gradually start drifting back
again now hopefully they'll find that
spot you actually wanted them to be in
in the first place so that's one thing
that can happen the other thing that can
happen is whatever you cue them to do
they can't actually do it but they wind
up doing what you want them to
accomplish so for example the the
classic cue when people squat and
deadlift I don't know if it's quite as
popular now but back in the day we'd
always say like keep your weight on your
heels and the thing is you don't
actually want your weight on your heels
when you squat and deadlift but if
someone would have a tendency to get
their weight really far forward to the
balls of their feet if you tell them put
your weight on your heels then what
actually ends up happening is it just
shifts back to mid foot where it should
be so you know you're you're not cueing
them to do what you actually want them
to do you're over cueing them such that
by over emphasizing a particular thing
they wind up in the position you
actually want them to be in so yeah just
a just a practical little coaching
coaching cue or coaching tip I think
people focus too much on cueing what
they actually want to be done versus
giving cues that will help athletes
accomplish that for themselves and and
like I said that firth that first method
of cueing of you know just actually
telling people what you want them to
accomplish that does work reasonably
well for someone who is learning a new
lift but
generally that stops working quite as
well when someone who knows the lifts
pretty well already winds up either with
a lift just not feeling good or dealing
with an intransigent technique issue
yeah I like how you put that because the
ultimately as a coach the goal of the
cue is not to be a logically sound
statement the goal of the cue is to
elicit a particular movement response
you know what I mean and so yeah you
have to give yourself license to again
like like you were saying overcorrect or
put them in a position as a kind of a
learning tool so that you can work
toward that the intended response
exactly yeah all right so this is a
segment that we've done previously
called research roundup and the general
premise here is going through some
recent research that came out in the
last month sometimes you see a few
studies or a couple studies that are on
similar topics and we'd like to go
through them and just let listeners know
hey here's some cool new stuff that came
out and kind of makes sense of a few
studies on the same topic so one of the
topics that had a couple papers this
month was fat free mass index and that's
a topic that's important to both of us I
know you've been talking about fat free
mass index for ages I published a paper
on it somewhere between one and six
years ago I forget when that thing came
out I feel like it was 2015-2016 that
sounds suitable sure that would make
sense
so this month there were two papers one
paper was looking at females the other
looking at males a full disclosure the
study involving college aged females I
was on the paper it was from my former
lab group at UNC the other study was by
a completely separate lab group which is
coincidental because like the titles of
the papers are almost like exactly the
same but in any case a couple parallel
studies that happen to be going on
around the same time the cool thing
about the one looking at college-age
females is that there's really not a ton
of fat free mass fat free mass index
research that was carried out in females
a lot of it just tends to be male
dominated so far
so without getting too far into detail I
mean it's it's one of the those studies
where it's like no one's looked at it so
let's get some kind of observational
data out there like what are the ranges
look like in college age females that do
these different activities so you know
there's not a lot of like remarkably
shocking conclusions from such a paper
because it really is just about
publishing data and getting some
reference ranges out there as kind of a
jumping-off point for this for this body
of literature that hopefully will what
we'll start to see more investigations
looking at this metric in in female
athletes so really to me one of the cool
things about this paper is that there's
there's some nice box and whisker plots
in the paper that kind of show ranges
for people involved with different types
of athletic activities so you know
there's gymnastics lacrosse
cross-country as you'd imagine the
cross-country team had had relatively
lower fat free mass index values than
the other teams and there were some you
know a lot of the teams the the median
values generally around 1718 some of the
upper quartile values just kind of
eyeballing the figure looks like they
might be in the 18 and 19 range and
there were select individuals that were
were up in the 20s and so there were at
least a couple but it looks like maybe
three or so that were between 20 and 22
and then there was one that looks like
it was over over 25 yeah it was 25 and a
half yeah so I mean that that's a that's
a really impressive number via Female
Athlete that's pretty wild now there was
a paper this month on fat free mass
index in what they call a diverse sample
of male college athletes and what they
mean by diverse is that there are quite
a few different sports represented
within the sample and this paper came
out of Chad Kirk six lab at Lindenwood
University and one of the cool things
about it is you know the paper I
published on fat free mass index a
couple years back we got a little bit of
pushback because some of the values were
higher than he
expected you know it I don't know how
many people actually really hold on to
this belief but there are like rumors
that 25 is kind of this hard cutoff for
what you know that kind of the high-end
limit of a fat free mass index value for
a drug-free male mmm-hmm and I don't I
haven't talked to a lot of people who
really hold that to be a firm rule have
you like is do people really feel that
way so here's what I'll say I've not
I've not come across anyone who's super
militant about that in person but I've
come across hundreds of people who are
super militant about that online yeah
because that's like I know it's a thing
and I know a lot of people post about it
but every time I talk to somebody about
it we usually agree on more than we
disagree you know what I mean so in any
case so that this particular paper they
had athletes doing baseball cross
country football rugby water polo
everything in between so it was over 200
total athletes I believe they used DEXA
for their fat free mass index
calculation is that correct I think so I
think so
and so much in line with what our group
found a couple years ago there were a
substantial number of athletes with a
fat free mass index above 25 and in some
cases well above 25 you know it looks
just eyeballing the figures quite a few
people that were above 27 up in the 28
range and then I think the highest was
just just a little bit shy of 31 even
and so I think what I was getting at the
general principle that it's hard to have
a value of 25 and be like 5% body fat I
think most people agree with that like
you got to be pretty special if you're
gonna be natural 5 or 6 percent body fat
and have a fat free mass index value of
25 like you're you're in very rarefied
air if that's who you are I'm the type
of person who doesn't immediately
translate
into an accusation like I usually like
to give people the benefit of the doubt
as long as it doesn't make me look
totally stupid but like what you tend to
find with fat-free mass index is to some
extent it scales with body fat and it
also you're gonna find it you're gonna
find higher values and people that are
genetically quite gifted mm-hmm so the
more that we do these types of studies
and get access to people who have
assistance with their training and
nutrition because they're college
athletes and especially when it comes to
like popular sports like football we
start to see athletes that are they're
born for this stuff to be big and strong
and muscular I I think one of the
reasons that we saw 25 as this limit is
because a lot of the you know the main
study indicating that was not in a group
of lifters you would assume to be
genetically particularly gifted yeah it
was just it was it was a sample from a
gym in Boston and a gym in LA and the
only inclusion criteria were that you
had to be over 16 years old and I
believe you had to have reported either
six months or two years of lifting it
was one of the two but it wasn't it
wasn't a particularly high bar right and
so in this case we're talking about if
you think of what are the inclusion
criteria of being a competitive
collegiate defensive lineman yeah the
inclusion criteria mean you're like fast
remarkably powerful and 300 pounds yeah
and then because you are that person now
you're on campus and you have access to
very qualified trainers typically a very
qualified nutrition staff often a
support in terms of accessing good food
there's a lot of benefit to that when it
comes to having a high fat free mass
index value yeah and so you know you see
papers like the one that that my group
published a few years back and then this
one now and it to me it's a little
I don't see the reason why people are
like justify why there are values over
25 I mean so here's what it comes down
to for me the original paper like I said
their or their sample was either 74 or
77 drug-free athletes and so if you're
attempting to establish a limit for any
human physical characteristic you're
gonna need a hell of a lot more than 70
something people to find that even if
even if you're looking for people in
like a really targeted population so
even if you just got a random sample of
74 NBA players who already skew
incredibly tall you're not gonna find
the tallest person who ever lived
you're not going to establish the limits
of human height or if you say went to an
international track meet and got all of
the hundred meter sprinters and said I
want to establish a limit of human speed
unless he got Usain Bolt at his peak in
your sample you're not gonna find it so
just getting a sample of 70 something
random lifters from a couple gyms yeah
there were probably a few people in that
sample who were very very well trained
but that's not going to be a sample
that's adequate for answering the
research question of what is the
absolute limit that someone could
possibly achieve drug for you there's a
lot to keep in mind when you're
considering like what's the highest fat
free mass index I could possibly hope
for and I think we ought to generally as
a collective group maybe chill with all
the accusations on people that are like
25 and a half impossible yeah you know
like come on yeah I mean cuz because the
thing is I think what you said before is
accurate that very few people probably
can achieve a fat-free mass index of 25
while being fairly lean but the thing
you need to keep in mind there is there
there is what we call in science in a
sload of people lifting weights and so
let's say one in a thousand can clear 25
I think it's probably more than that but
let's just say it's one in a thousand
let's say it's one in 10,000 if there's
10 million people lifting and one in
10,000 can have a fat-free mass index
over 25 then that's still a thousand
people running around out there with a
fat free mass index over 25 if it's
closer to like you know one in a hundred
that's still rare but now we're talking
about tens of thousands of people who
could who could clear that theoretical
hurdle so the it's not sufficient
evidence to make an accusation that
someone is committing a federal felony
to say well what this person has done is
unlikely because when you extrapolate
some in unlikely single event across a
huge population now it becomes virtually
a certainty that someone can do it and
are you sure enough that it's not this
person you're accusing that you're
willing to so here here's the
illustration I like to use like if you
want to see a picture of a skinny person
online and just automatically comment
like well that person's been smoking
crack like if if you one if you would do
that you're a piece of [ __ ] who that is
functionally identical to seeing a
picture of someone who's either like
really jacked or lifts a lot of weight
and saying like yep they're on drugs
like it's the same thing yeah now
another topic that had a couple papers
this month was dietary nitrate and that
is a topic that's near and dear to my
heart because that was one of the key
pieces of my dissertation work now one
of the papers was a review paper about
dietary nitrate nitrate and physical
performance and it was fine you know
it's another narrative review that just
kind of says hey here's this growing
body of research on nitrate but the
thing that jumped out at me about this
review is that more than ever it looks
like the reviews are starting to drift
away from conventional aerobic endurance
exercise with nitrate and and drift
closer toward
brint power and strength type outcomes
and so a separate piece of literature
there's a researcher named Coggan Co GGN
and that researcher has released a few
papers over the last couple years
showing that it's quite possible that
dietary nitrate does in fact have a
direct effect on the muscle that is
causing enhanced forced output so that's
something that if you check out the
article on the site stronger by science
com I wrote a big article about nitric
oxide boosters I go into a little more
detail about the the it's uncertain but
there's a decent possibility that nitric
oxide booster supplements might be
useful to a strength athlete someone
who's interested in lifting weights
because we're starting to uncover some
direct effects of nitrate on muscle
contractile function which is pretty
cool now one of the big challenges about
turning that into a useful piece of
information is how do we actually get a
consistently useful dose of nitrate and
so that brings me to the second paper on
nitrate that came out this month it's
called what is in your beet juice
nitrate and nitrite content of beet
juice products marketed to athletes now
what they do is they took samples from
45 different lots of 24 different
beetroot juice products and these were
from 21 different companies that's
pretty thorough yeah I didn't realize
there were there were that many products
on the market yeah yes I mean they made
a pretty broad sweep and what they were
doing is basically saying okay let's buy
these products and let's check out the
nitrate content and see what we get and
so the the the real key findings here is
there was a pretty big coefficient of
variation within the same product okay
and that was about 30 percent plus or
minus 26 percent the range being to 283
that's so crazy so the moral of the
story there is even with the same
product wildly discrepant nitrate
content
and if you're using the product for the
nitrate which you are that's a problem
yeah now but that's within product now
we're talking about comparing one
product to another and they found about
a 50 fold range in nitrate content
between the lowest and the highest
product of these I think they said 24
different products only five of them
consistently had a nitrate dose that was
greater than or equal to five millimoles
which you could more or less consider to
be like the bare minimum of what you'd
be looking for for an ergogenic effect
so to be clear that 50 fold range is
insane well some had enough and some
some just massively overdosed it that's
that's a small handful had barely enough
and then at least someone was giving you
two percent of what you actually needed
right yeah it was basically like you
were there were a couple products that
were a little higher than you'd think
and I'd part of that was because they
didn't the researchers noted in a couple
instances they had to kind of infer what
the suggested dose was because the
labeling was it was pretty vague very
cool but there were a couple that were a
little higher than you'd think but not
by a ton yeah it's certainly nothing
that would be hazardous to your health
but but no as you're mentioning the
overwhelming concern was a lot of people
sold you nitrate that did not have much
nitrate so yeah there was a lot of
products with just almost none or just
an amount that you just couldn't be
bothered to to care about and frankly
even five millimoles is if I were taking
nitrate from a supplement I'd probably
be shooting for more in the eight
millimole range mm-hmm so yeah it's it's
a as I always tell people with nitrate
supplements it's a pretty pretty not
great state of affairs if you're
interested in going out and getting a
reliable product so here's the thing
that's tricky though
is I often tell people will just get it
from food
and there is a study by a port Porcelli
or Porcelli at all 2016 where they using
food sources fruit and vegetable sources
of nitrate they they basically gave
people a daily nitrate dose of 8.2
millimoles per day which is about 500
milligrams and that they did find that
to be an effective dose from food but
even in the food supply nitrate content
can be quite unpredictable and so
there's a study by de Gonzales at all in
2015 and this was a really cool study I
really loved this one but they went out
to grocery stores in five different
cities Chicago Dallas LA New York and
Raleigh Elia we made it and what they
did was they just grabbed conventional
produce off the shelf and tested the
nitrate and some of the surprising
numbers in that study the average
nitrate content of spinach in New York
was 564 parts per million in Dallas it
was over 4,900 so 564 versus 4900 as the
average that's wild
yeah now the lowest spinach content they
got from New York was 65 parts per
million and the highest they got in LA
was 8,000 parts per million that's
ridiculous
so one of the things that makes me a
little bit
I hesitate to get to just pile on these
supplement companies too aggressively
because like even in the food supply
like unless you're being really thorough
on the the supplement manufacturing end
which they should be you know to be
clear but but like with a lot of
ingredients if you saw that level of
variation you'd be like you guys are
absolute monsters like Hugh crooks it's
possible that I mean they certainly
should be more thorough but even in in
conventional produce it's tough to know
exactly how much nitrate is going to be
in the the produce that you purchase and
so you know there are some good products
like beet it's port in the study that we
started talking about
the way they actually measured all those
different products beat it sport did
quite well on their testing so that's a
pretty solid product out there it is a
bit pricey which is yeah didn't you say
it's either like a buck fifty or two
dollars a dose
I believe it's three dollars a dose she
if you buy them in in in like a big
package that's wild and you could make
the argument that you probably ought to
have two doses pre-workout instead of
one so that that's a huge factor for
that yeah so what I normally tell people
with nitrate is there it's there's a
good possibility that there is some
organic benefit to be obtained there
your best bet in my opinion currently
until some of these companies do a
better job
standardizing their nitrate content is
to emphasize higher nitrate foods in the
diet and basically put your money on the
law of averages and assume that like
every time you get spinach it's not
going to be 65 parts per million unless
you live in New York yeah if you live in
New York then it's bad regardless our IP
your damn arteries yeah you guys really
got to figure out your spinach situation
in New York very disappointing
very disappointing but no I mean I I
still think that one of the things I
think is the benefit of going with the
food sources like even though there's
variability like if you're eating a
bunch of high nitrate foods you're gonna
get some nitrate mm-hmm and more
importantly what I always tell people is
let's say you eat in a high nitrate diet
in principle but you actually got
shorted on your nitrate content a little
bit the downside of that was you just
accidentally ate a bunch of celery and
spinach and arugula and a bunch of crap
that's gonna make you live forever even
so like if that's the downside of your
your dosing strategy you're gonna be
alright
it's like all the side effects make you
live longer so probably a good move sure
enough we just talked about caffeine and
caffeine actually did pop up in the
literature this month and I feel like
there's a lot of caffeine stuff coming
out these days
it's like every month or if there's
quite a few caffeine studies coming out
but the thing that's nice is they're
doing cool work yeah it's not like when
like creatine back in the day I got in
this groove where hey
creatine increases reps to fatigue on
benchpress still and I was like just a
million of those yeah and I did I do a
study myself on creatine and reps to
fatigue you bet I did
so that that's me absolutely dissing
myself in front of a microphone but in
any case a lot of the caffeine studies
that are coming out these days are there
answering cool questions yeah so we've
talked in the past I want to talk too
much about caffeine because this is
going to become like the stronger by
science caffeine podcast at some point
but we talked about how there's some
genetic factors that seem to be related
to caffeine certainly we know that
there's genetic variation with the the
enzymes that metabolize caffeine but the
question is what are the ramifications
of that and so I think we're going to
see a lot more of these studies coming
out one of the studies this month
basically what they did was they looked
at a big sample of people I think the
the data set was I think the data were
collected in the South Paulo area as a
big data set and what they were looking
at was the certain genetic determinants
that make you more likely to have high
blood pressure and they're trying to see
if there's any relationship between how
caffeine might affect outcomes in that
case and and what this study found was
there was apparently a gene diet
interaction and what they found was that
if you were proposed a pre disposed it's
a high blood pressure due to these
genetic variants caffeine seem to seem
to interact with that in the case that
being predisposed to high blood pressure
and consuming relatively higher amounts
of coffee was was generally not great
for your long-term blood pressure
outcomes now it's really important to
highlight like I said we we're gonna see
a lot of these over the next ten years
we've seen a few already we've seen
papers looking at how genes affect
performance responses to caffeine how
they affect various cardiovascular
outcomes even some stuff looking at bone
density outcomes and right now the the
consensus is that we don't have one it's
it's pretty mixed research at this time
I think generally speaking when it comes
to the genetic component of caffeine
metabolism if you had to lean one way or
the other like if you submitted a
genetic test and had to cross your
fingers and hope for one it would appear
tentatively you'd probably like to be a
fast metabolizer
than a slow but you know we're still
just starting to kind of piece together
how genes interact with our various
responses to caffeine and so in this
case it looked like I should clarify a
lot of those papers were looking at the
genetic inheritance of the cyp 1a2
enzyme which is responsible for caffeine
metabolism largely there's a couple
other ones like the the adora there's
one or two of those that that are genes
associated with caffeine I think those
are with the adenosine receptor which is
how caffeine works in this particular
study the genes they were looking at
were specifically tied to high blood
pressure so these were not caffeine
related genes per se but again what they
found was if you were predisposed to
high blood pressure due to your genetics
in that scenario
having the hike at high caffeine intake
from coffee appear to be a somewhat
negative thing which is a bummer yeah
that sucks is it gonna stop me from
drinking caffeine let me rephrase that
nothing's gonna stop me from drinking
caffeine now another study came out
caffeine supplementation gurga genic in
both high and low caffeine responders
and this was an interesting one so they
were looking at trained soccer players
and they distinguished them as either
high or low caffeine responders and the
way they did it was
they basically gave them a dose of
caffeine and looked at a variety of
responses including their resting blood
pressure their plasma glycerol
non-esterified fatty acid and
epinephrine response to a caffeine dose
and basically what they said was if
caffeine elicited large responses in
those various outcomes we're gonna
consider you a high responder and if not
we're gonna consider you a low responder
so I feel like this is I feel like this
is essentially just doing the exact same
thing as the studies that have looked at
people who are habituated to caffeine
are naive to it
it's just stratifying them based on
something else because if you're
habituated to the effects of caffeine
that is going to affect your that that
will affect most of the things they
looked at so the more habituated you are
probably the less effect caffeine will
have on blood pressure less effect it
will have on glycerol etc certainly the
smaller the effect will be that it has
on plasma epinephrine levels so on its
face I kind of like this design better
because theoretically people build up
different levels of tolerance to
caffeine but you're primarily interested
in whether the physiological effects of
that tolerance negate the effects of
caffeine on its its ergogenic effects to
your organic benefits on exercise so
this is basically just saying well we're
gonna cut out the middleman
who cares if you're habituated to it or
not we want to see if you have a
physiological response that looks like
you're super habituated to it or not so
I think it's I like this I think it's
its stratifying based on something that
makes more sense yeah so basically as
you're you're saying if you were
habituated then you would probably have
pretty minimal responses in these
different outcomes so that that probably
is a better way I mean a lot of times
with the habituation literature they
kind of give a little questionnaire try
to get some kind of self-reported
assessment of whether or not they
consume a lot of caffeine and I think
though I think we put a little too much
faith
and exactly how accurate those R's
mm-hmm how accurate those are in terms
of distinguishing between someone who's
truly physiologically habituated and
somebody who isn't but in any case what
they found in the case of this study is
that the caffeine improved aerobic
endurance and neuromuscular performance
and it did not really seem to be
affected by whether or not they were in
that what they call the high responder
or low responder group and so what this
tells us is as you were alluding to it
kind of fits in with a lot of that
habituation literature on caffeine which
would suggest that generally speaking if
we stratify a group by whether or not
they're habituated or naive we don't
seem to see really substantial
differences in terms of their
performance response to the caffeine now
longitudinal studies do show a little
bit of performance obituaries recently
in Mass but but this is another study
showing that even though some of these
resting parameters might vary in
response to caffeine
caffeine's its track record when it
comes to improving performance seems to
be looking pretty strong the more that
we do some of these studies yeah and the
question always is when you talk about
caffeine habituation is like is it
having an ergonomic effect or once
you've become habituated to it is it
just keeping you at baseline and you
would otherwise have like big
performance decrements possibly due to
withdrawal symptoms without it and from
where I'm sitting I don't really care
like regardless of whether you're
habituated to it or not you perform
better on caffeine than not on caffeine
and if you want to potentially Rison
citize yourself to the effects of
caffeine the first place I would look at
cutting back on caffeine intake probably
want to be around my workout yeah
now a cool thing about that caffeine
study is it it ties in well with the
next kind of cluster or pairing of
studies
came out this month which we're looking
at statistical issues in methodology so
there's a paper called issues in the
determination of responders and
non-responders in physiological research
and there have been a few papers that
have come out on that recently in the
exercise science literature and frankly
I don't think we're anywhere near a
consensus on exactly how that should be
done but I do think it's important that
a lot of statisticians and and kind of
methods focused people are at least
thinking about it because the more that
you look back at some of these studies
that have kind of boldly separated into
these two dichotomous groups mm-hmm
whenever you see that it's really
important to look at how they made that
determination and even just you know
aside from all the complex ways to deal
with variation within a sample just at
face value does it feel okay you know I
mean well so I mean here's the I think
that the usage of the term non-responder
and science helps illustrate just how
large of a role tradition plays in
science so if someone publishes the
first paper in an area subsequent papers
are probably going to use similar
terminology to that that was coined in
the first paper likely going to use
similar statistical methods at least the
first few papers are probably going to
use pretty similar study designs and
some of that stuff can stick around for
a long time so to the best of my
knowledge either the first or one of the
first people to use the term
non-responder at least in terms of
resistance training research was Baumann
from University of Alabama at Birmingham
and if he wasn't the first
I know his papers looking at
non-responders were certainly very big
and well sited so that's where I think a
lot of that tradition came from I was
talking to one of his PhD students a
couple years ago because I was
considering applying to UAB for grad
school
and I was like oh yeah like I like
Bauman's research really interesting I
liked his non-responder stuff and his
student came back to me and he's like
yeah he hates that terminology now like
he wishes he wouldn't have used it and
virtually every person that I've talked
to who either has worked in a lab where
non-responder research has come out or
has published research looking at
non-responders they all hate the
terminology but it's one of those things
that has been used so much in the
literature it's just kind of expected
that if you're if you're looking at you
know if you do some sort of intervention
and some people don't see robust
adaptations to whatever that
intervention is you call them
non-responders and no one likes that
term but we haven't just stopped using
it at some point
yeah when it comes down to in a study
looking at responder non-responders
statistically there are ways to do it I
really like how it I think it makes
sense in the creatine literature because
it's it's quite identifiable by a tissue
sample you know like like we can that's
a thing yeah and and that's the that's
the discriminating factor there right so
someone may absolutely be an on
responder to creatine they just maybe
have naturally high creatine levels
taking more creatine doesn't increase
their creatine stores it doesn't do
anything for them the response may be
that they excrete more creatine but
that's not the sort of response you
would say they've responded to creatine
whereas with exercise like everyone
responds to exercise it's just a
question of how you respond to it maybe
it is going to cause some sort of
adaptation definitely and the thing I
always caution people about I've seen
this in papers which is why I tell
people like whenever you seen
non-responder or responder in a paper
like immediately go to the methods and
try to figure out what the hell that
means
yeah think about one characteristic
right and like I have seen papers where
honest to god they just say we took
the top half of responses just the
people who did really really well mm-hmm
we categorized them as responders and
everybody else's non responders we did a
special subgroup analysis and it turns
out this supplement works really well in
responders and it's like that's the most
intellectually disingenuous [ __ ] I've
ever heard you can't just take everybody
that happens to be above the mean yeah
and say well well in them it works cuz
you should have about half of them below
the mean yeah if we if we take something
that does jack [ __ ] and just happen to
have half of the people just do two
[ __ ] measurement error wind up with
responses greater than zero percent
better than they were before and just
rerun an analysis on them like yeah the
the minimum number in your sample is
going to be greater than zero therefore
like whatever you're looking at will be
different from zero yeah god damn it
yeah I've seen that a couple times it's
not super common but you know I think
it's good that some of these papers are
coming out so that we're gonna have more
of a conversation in the field of like
we need to really figure out if we don't
have a biological obvious criteria for
distinguishing mm-hmm if we're gonna do
this thing mathematically we need to
figure out what our criteria are and
really get on board with I mean it
honestly just gets me a little hot under
the collar that something like that
cleared peer review well it happens
cuz that's that's [ __ ] egregious yeah
it wasn't good yeah but it was like one
of those things that there was just a
very clearly arbitrary set non-response
threshold where they just said well what
would be convenient to look at and
that's where the line got drawn Jesus
now I don't to go on and on about stats
but there was a really cool paper it's
called the fragility of statistically
significant results from Clinical
Nutrition randomized controlled trials
and this isn't like totally in
everybody's wheelhouse that listens to
the podcast in terms of content area but
there's like one punchline for this
study that is just
worth its weight in gold really valuable
lesson here so they took they took 37
studies they did this very rigorous
selection process to make sure they had
studies that fit their criteria all
these studies were looking at
dichotomous outcomes so with they had
these like two different groups and like
you know the outcome measurement either
you know happened or it didn't that's
what did you get this disease did you
not exactly did you not exactly yeah did
you meet X weight loss threshold or did
you not stuff like that yeah so
dichotomous outcomes and what they were
looking at is something called the
fragility index and basically what it
does is it indicates the minimum number
of patients whose status would have to
change in order to basically reverse the
outcome of the the analysis so like if
one person who had the condition didn't
if one person switched over and then all
of a sudden your significant finding
became non significant the fragility
index would be one if just one person
went the other way you're finding
disappears and according to old school
scientists is no longer meaningful or
interesting so that that's basically
what they were looking at is how many
individual subjects in these studies had
to go the other way for the outcome of
the study to be reversed the entire
conclusion and so what they found was in
it from the studies they looked at the
value was lower than or equal to two in
three-quarters of the studies that they
looked at which means again from that
literature they sampled and they started
with a big kind of cross section of the
nutrition literature how did they come
up with their sample of studies they
looked at they had a whole like flow
chart of inclusion criteria okay but it
was it was a standardized process yeah
it was a systematic search of the way
okay yeah that's good and so yeah so
think of that 75% of the trials if one
or two subjects had gone the other
direction the finding would have been
reversed so we've talked about P curves
on this podcast but
which i think makes us the only like non
stats podcast to ever talk about P
curves I feel very comfortable that
that's the case yeah but I feel like
this is kind of doing kind of
approaching the same thing oh yeah but
for individual studies instead of an
entire body of literature like if you P
curve to those [ __ ] studies you know
that P curves gonna look [ __ ] awful
oh yeah cuz yeah I mean these studies
I'm going completely from the gut here
kind of shooting from the hip but if
your fragility index is one or two like
for 75% of the literature like those
p-values are probably all 0.04 yeah I
know I'm not going to make any
accusations about any individual study
within those three quarters but you have
to know some sort of statistical [ __ ]
went on in a decent number of those
papers where they just looked at it and
they're like well you know we screamed
this one person into our study but now
that I think about it did they really
belong I wonder what our p-value is if
we exclude them right yeah you know what
I'm saying like another meaningful thing
here is that when you lose patience to
follow up in a study or subjects to
follow up there's kind of an ongoing
debate about like well do you do your
analysis with the people that finish the
study or what do you do with these
people that didn't finish where do you
categorize them how do you factor them
into that analysis and so in one-third
of the studies they looked at the
fragility index was lower than the
number of patients that were lost due to
follow-up and so that's another thing
where that statistical decision of how
you deal with that would have completely
inverted the outcome of the study
theoretically so whenever we tell people
you like you never assume that a single
study is really telling you the entire
story for a body of literature this kind
of concept comes to mind of within a
single analysis that the small
collection of things that could happen
mm-hmm within a single study to
completely invert your conclusion that's
why it's so critical not to see one
study
come and say well that's below my
arbitrary threshold
yeah 105 and say glad we figured that
out yeah and I mean another thing that
I'll add to that is one of the reasons
why I think a lot of folks tell people
like ah you know you should leave
reading the literature and interpreting
it to the experts is because like we
know that this [ __ ] goes on we know that
oftentimes when you look at a paper the
findings probably aren't as clean as the
authors would like to present them as
maybe a false positive they may have
done something untoward to get the
results that they got and there there
are some little things you can look at
that might be hints that something like
that went on but one of the things that
you dear listener can take home which is
super super easy to do is if a paper
reports p-values your confidence in the
results should probably scale with how
close or how far those p-values are from
0.05 if you see something where you know
it's 0.04 7 you know they not making any
accusations the authors very much could
have done everything on the up-and-up
but that's probably a pretty iffy
finding if something's 0.0001 it's it's
probably legit like that probably would
be a study you could cite as evidence of
something would absolutely be good if it
was replicated but that's probably going
to be a durable finding versus something
where like the confidence interval is
you know like all up in zeros face like
as close as it could possibly be without
crossing it yeah
and now another tool you can use to make
inferences about whether or not you care
about a finding would be the effect size
right so it's not just about the p-value
we want to know how big of an effect did
we actually see and one of the things
that comes up I think every month we
talk about this when we kind of survey
the new batch of studies that came out
and this month was as bad if not worse
than any but we're talking about effect
sizes here
and honestly right now if you were to
ask me hey Eric what can you tell me
about interpreting effect sizes when I
read the exercise science literature I
would tell you when you come across an
effect size number I want you write it
down on a piece of paper I want you to
put that paper in an envelope I want to
take it to your fireplace I want you to
burn it because that means nothing to me
that's a hot take it means nothing to me
because the number of effect sizes we
see in this body of literature that are
either wrong objectively just we don't
know where that number came from but
that ain't it or wildly misinterpreted
yeah it's you just I don't know what to
do with it
so for once I'm going to say I think
that take was a little too hot I know
well I would I would instead do is write
it down on a piece of paper look and see
if the data was reported in tables
anywhere and make sure it was calculated
correctly fine and then if it wasn't
throw it in a fire but I'm just so sick
of it man dude so what what Eric is
getting at is so most of the effect
sizes that are reported in the exercise
science literature are what's called a
Cohen's D sometimes you'll get a Hedges
G but they're effectively the same thing
a Hedges G it just also applies a
correction for small sample research to
make it a little bit more conservative
but a Cohen's D effectively answers the
question for you by how many standard
deviations do these two things differ or
by how many standard deviations did this
particular thing change and so for
example if you have a sample of people
whose average benchpress is a hundred
kilos with a standard deviation of 20
kilos and their bench presses improved
by 10 kilos on average that would be a
Cohen's D effect size of 0.5 so you have
a 10 a 10 kilo improvement divided by 20
kilo standard deviation you can say on
average these subjects improved by about
half a standard deviation and that's how
it's supposed to be done but how is it
often done Eric what's often done is
rather than dividing by the standard
deviation of the measurement they will
divide by the standard deviation of the
change and that's problematic for two
reasons so first of all at a very basic
conceptual level you are dividing by two
very different things which means that
you have to interpret those values
extremely differently even from just a
very theoretical perspective we are now
looking at essentially two completely
different concepts the other problem is
that when you divide by the standard
deviation of the change it tends to be a
much smaller number so the result of
that is a very inflated effect size now
if you look at the literature pertaining
to Cohen's D you find that Cohen's D is
really a a family of values there are
many different subtypes and many
different ways to calculate those
subtypes so it's not objectively wrong
to use some form of Cohen's D that
divides by the standard deviation of the
change but my problem is when people do
that and they make no effort to label it
as such and furthermore they actually
often interpret it as if it was a very
different type of Cohen's D and so what
what they end up doing is saying wow
this was an extremely large change
without factoring in the the very
obvious consideration that they divided
by an unusually small number yes so just
to make it clear for the listeners so
going back to that example if group
benches 100 plus or minus 20 kilos their
benchpress improves by 10 kilos plus or
minus 2 kilos let's say so the
improvement was 10 plus or minus 2 then
what some people will do is they'll
calculate that effect size as the 10
kilo change divided by the standard
deviation of the change which is 2 kilos
and then say oh now that's an effect
size of 5
and so just to put this in context the
traditional way of interpreting effect
sizes is is if it's less than point two
it's considered trivial if it's between
two and point five it's considered
medium or moderate if it's between 0.5
and point 8 it's considered or no if
it's between point 2 and point 5 it's
considered small between 0.5 and point 8
is medium or moderate and above point 8
is considered large you're not
necessarily slave to those
interpretations because you know for
some applications like you know let's
say you're talking about elite level
athletes if they improve by 0.3 standard
deviations in that context that may be a
really really big improvement versus you
know if you get a excise of 0.8 in
untrained lifters in terms of like
strength gains over 16 weeks really
that's a pretty small effect in that
population so there is some subjectivity
and interpretation but those are the
figures generally used and certainly
you'll you will virtually never see an
effect size above like 2 or 3 so by but
what can happen is if you calculate it
by the change divided by the standard
deviation of the change unless the
change was just unbelievably variable
unless this the standard deviation of
the change was larger than the standard
deviation of the characteristic within
the population pre-training it's just
going to massively inflate your effect
sizes right so you effectively wind up
with you know grouping increases their
benchpress by 10 kilos yeah that's
pretty good
it's a medium effect but if you
calculate that effect size as 5 now
you're saying like wow this is the most
unbelievably huge effect on benchpress
performance we have ever seen and it's
just dumb like right and there there are
times where you could calculate that
metric which is you know using the
change standard deviation as the
denominator and you could make useful
inferences based on it but in the
exercise science literature you just
don't see it clear
labeled and interpreted as such what
what you see almost all the time is
conflating those two very different
numbers as the same thing and taking
this wildly inflated estimate of what
you could call an effect size but acting
like it's that original scaled value
correct and saying wow we saw a huge
effect yeah and so and it turns out that
the actual change is like two kilos plus
or minus half a kilo but it's an effect
size of four right yeah so it's inflated
numbers and again that even if it was
just that and the literature I could get
over it but a lot of times you're just
you're looking at the table with the
values that were used to cope to
calculate the effect size and you're
like there's no way this combination of
numbers would give you that effect size
right and use whatever standard
deviation you want and the reason it's
so frustrating
to me at least is that like stats can
get really hairy and even some of the
things that are used frequently in
statistics can be a little bit confusing
or take you a little a little while to
figure out exactly how to interpret them
how they would be calculated a lot of
calculations you probably wouldn't want
to do by hand like a p-value for
instance like the the basic
understanding of it isn't that hard but
people who are really into stats like
we've both seen people say like oh I
need a good solid thousand words to
explain to you exactly what a p-value is
or or or they'll say like no one should
ever try yeah or like in ephra show like
you know it's going to be very difficult
to calculate by hand it's kind of a
theoretical construct what that actually
represents but an effect size is
incredibly straightforward and a [ __ ]
second grader could calculate it it's by
how many standard deviations did
something change or by how many standard
deviations are these two things
different like that's a pretty simple
understanding and that's not a
simplified understanding that is what it
actually is and it's one number divided
by another number like that's that's how
the [ __ ] you calculated it is
most basic concept that is frequently
used in in our statistical methods in
exercise science and probably a good
solid 20 to 30 percent of the studies
that use it [ __ ] it up I know and it's
it's outrageous I know it's not okay
it's not okay it's not okay all right
now you came across a study this month
about sleep and you were going to inform
us all about recovery from sleep I guess
basically the study was looking at like
trying to overcome a sleep debt
essentially is that a fair
characterization yeah so this study was
titled two nights of recovery sleep
restores dynamic light pima course ponds
are like PIM Achra spawns but not the
reduction in insulin sensitivity induced
by five nights of sleep restriction and
so this is a really cool title in that
it basically tells you how the study was
conducted and what the findings were
they took people who habitually slept
pretty well slept about eight hours a
night they had a lead in phase of a
couple days had them in the lab in bed
for ten hours a night not necessarily
sleeping ten hours a night but they got
eight and a half nine hours for a couple
nights just to make sure everyone was
had a good baseline and then they tested
they tested insulin sensitivity and some
metrics associated with free fatty acids
in the blood and then they had them
sleep for five hours a night for five
nights and then they had them in bed for
ten hours a night for another two nights
so they were basically trying to mimic a
work week during which you sleep five
hours a night on work nights and you
sleep in two days on the weekends and
basically you're able to sleep as much
as you want and so what they found is
that insulin sensitivity and the blood
lipid response got pretty substantially
worse after five nights of poor sleep
and then after two nights of recovery
sleep to try to make up that sleep debt
the the
three fatty acid kinetics those were
back to baseline those looked pretty
good again but insulin sensitivity not
only was it not back to baseline it
basically didn't improve at all insulin
sensitivity decreased by roughly a third
during the five nights of sleep
restriction after the two days of sleep
recovery it was basically where it had
been prior or it was basically where it
had been at the end of the sleep of the
sleep restriction so just two nights of
recovery sleep didn't really seem to do
much to bring that back so theoretically
if you have insulin insensitivity
induced by poor sleep you're probably
going to need
well you certainly need longer than two
days to bring that back but probably
even longer than that that's really
discouraging yeah it'd be really nice to
live in a world where you could just
totally mess something up for five days
and then fix it in two I would like that
yeah and I think that's something that
people are becoming more savvy to now
that like Matthew Walker's profile
worldwide has increased a lot he's he's
a hotshot sleep researcher probably
probably one of the best-known sleep
researchers and and certainly the
best-known popularizer of sleep research
he's gotten a lot more press over the
years put out a book called why we sleep
I believe is the title of it so now
people are getting savvy to this but
this used to be less well-known by folks
that essentially you can't fully make up
for a sleep debt to fully get the
benefits of good sleep you need to sleep
well night in and night out and you know
one or two bad nights isn't gonna kill
you but if you sleep bad every weeknight
and then just try to make up for it on
the weekends you can't do it it's
certainly better to make up to attempt
to make up for it on the weekends and
also to sleep like [ __ ] on the weekends
but it's not it's not just not as good
as sleeping well every night it's not
even close to as good alright to play us
out today a new paper that came out this
month
called putting out the fire efficacy of
common beverages in reducing oral burn
from capsaicin so this was a nice
light-hearted study if you've ever eaten
spicy things and wondered what kind of
beverage can get me out of this Jam
there is brand new hot off the presses
science to help you with your problem so
the reason I brought the study up was
was twofold first of all I wanted to
highlight it they're very very
controversial decision to categorize I
can't even say it
they said it at one point in the paper
that they use the term fruit punch and I
was like they didn't use fruit punch and
they categorized kool-aid as fruit punch
it seems to be a very generous
interpretation of what kool-aid is
that's literally right out of a
Chappelle show sketch so so yeah I saw
that and I was like okay I need to I
need to bring this to the attention of
the world now if you are interested in
the outcome of the study
eating spicy things makes your mouth
uncomfortably hot but a few of the
beverages that did quite well we're
whole milk kool-aid and skim milk beer
and Cola did fine a little bit better
than water but not by much
all the beverages helped to some extent
so they the ones that didn't do a ton
included seltzer and just regular water
but yeah I mean I drink a lot of
kool-aid growing up believe me it was
like the only thing I drank so kool-aid
always had a special place in my heart
so it's nice to see that it's making its
way into the peer-reviewed literature
and succeeding in the process which was
your favorite kool-aid oh I really like
the grape okay I thought the grape was
really good what about you probably the
grape as well yeah the grape was very
good they knew what they were doing
alright so now that we've covered
literally all of this month's scientific
research on kool-aid it is time for the
interview portion of the show we've got
a great interview with dr. Brad dieter
you might know Brad from eat to perform
macros Inc he's involved with a bunch of
other companies and projects and I sat
down with Brad and we talked a little
bit about
artificial sweeteners processed foods
body fat set points and much much more
so it's a really great interview stay
tuned and I hope you enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
so we got Brad here
first of all Brad thank you so much for
coming on today yeah of course man this
is awesome I'm excited to talk to you I
think the last time you and I chatted we
were both in the Midwest and it'll be
nice to just reconnect and get caught up
yeah we were both talking at the that
macros Inc conference in in Chicago and
yeah it's good to talk to you again this
one's gonna be different okay so on this
show it's gonna be very combative very
adversarial and we purposely don't do
video because I don't you know I feel
like we'll both agree that you've skated
along your whole career with your good
looks this is audio only okay so it's
going we're going toe to toe and it's
just ideas okay so you got a hold your
own today all right I'll get up the
intellectual boxing gloves and see what
we can come up with beautiful the more
combative the better I mean you people
listening gonna are you were on like a
billboard right yeah I've been on a few
yeah a few oh my god we actually have
the people who did um just called me
like two weeks goes like we have all
your billboards so now I have four I
think they're like 18 by 40 foot
billboards just fold it up in my garage
I don't know what I'm gonna do with them
well you have the actual billboards oh
yeah yep yeah so if you're listview this
you may have heard that brad is charming
and handsome that's that's fake news
it's a nasty rumor that's going around
trust me
he's not that good-looking I don't know
how he swindled these people into
putting him on a billboard it's
definitely not because him and his wife
are a beautiful couple it was like a
marriage thing right yeah it's it's all
my wife I give her all the credit for
that all right so you know we met in
Chicago and we're hanging out and
normally this is a bad thing but I mean
this in the most I mean this as a
compliment but if you've ever seen the
the movie office space they're they're
interviewing a guy and they say what
exactly is it that you do around here
so normally that means like do you do
anything but when we are hanging out in
Chicago I couldn't really wrap my head
around all the stuff you have going on
your cut you it seems like you've got a
lot of irons in the fire so do you mind
giving us a little introduction about
basically your background and what it is
that you currently do yeah so I'll try
to summarize my background as quick as
possible not to eat up too much people's
time so I did my undergrad thought about
going to med school decided not to do
that I went back and got my masters we
focused on biomechanics doing
electrophysiology work and then got more
interested in kind of the physiology
piece so I did a PhD in exercise
physiology and looked I primarily did
molecular biology work and used exercise
as kind of a therapeutic modality and
looked at you know genetic regulation
and the heart and then I did a
fellowship in nephrology where I did a
lot more molecular work and I also kind
of during my PhD my fellowship in my
staff scientist career faculty scientist
career I did a lot of data analytic work
kind of just built up a data science
background too and kind of when I was
when I started my fellowship I kind of
started doing a lot more industry work
and started kind of the entrepreneur
route and joined a company called e to
perform and kind of built that up and
turn that from more of a like
information product business into a
coaching business and then into a
software technology business so that's
been a big project of mine over the last
few years
I just left kind of formal academia in
about September although a lot of the
work that I was working on it's just
finally being published so welcome to
the dark side yes
yeah the dark side that you used to be a
real scientist I used to be a real
scientist and now I just kind of tell
people how to do science that's kind of
mostly what I do so I am no longer in
academia but I'm kind of fully in
industry entrepreneurship mode I run so
I co run eat
form I also am on the scientific
advisory board for several companies and
kind of lead their there are D and kind
of help them with all their all their
biotech stuff and then just all the
other little projects that I'm involved
in here and there so basically you were
a scientist then you started getting
into a Gary Vaynerchuk videos near like
oh my god I need to be an entrepreneur
you know what's so funny is my approach
to almost everything is the opposite of
his maybe that's why he's almost a
billionaire and I'm like I made a joke
to my wife the other day when we went to
Vegas for a weekend I was like maybe
we'll leave thousand airs and come home
ten thousand airs so maybe that's maybe
that's where I went wrong maybe so okay
so you've got a very diverse background
and I bet your your data science
background is probably very strong
because that's a lot of different types
of data that you've dealt with with all
those different focuses I would imagine
yeah you know that's been one of the the
most interesting things is you know kind
of having this data science is a skill
and then looking at it from you know all
the different types of data input it
really it's been really eye-opening
because you start to realize when people
are kind of looking at data they're
analyzing data they're publishing it
whether it's in economic space the
health space the you know financial
space is the output of what you see is
based on a lot of assumptions and I
think a lot of times there's not a lot
of thought given to the assumptions of
what goes into it and so that's been
probably the most helpful thing is you
know having the the fairly rigorous you
know medical background training as
brutal as it can be really kind of makes
you be very thoughtful and how you think
about you know the inputs of what you're
analyzing so that's been really really
interesting yeah so now you find
yourself in a position you've got this
diverse background you're more into the
the private sector and you know one of
the reasons I said like what do you do
around here is because you're the stuff
you put out is so relevant and it's so
comprehensive I feel like you've you've
a little footing in several different
areas but the the kind of general
nutrition stuff that you put out on
social media and different articles is
really really good stuff very helpful
and it's important that we have people
like you who have this strong science
background and strong statistics
background that are still you know
contributing this stuff straight to the
people using the information so I want
to ask you about a couple things you've
put out lately just on social media you
know there's a recent paper about
artificially sweetened beverages do you
mind giving a little background about
exactly what the paper looked like yeah
so this was I'm trying to think this was
probably in February so it's about two a
month and a half ago and a paper came
out basically showing that you know
people who drink more basically diet
sodas are more likely to have negative
health outcomes right so I always try to
be in these into really broad ideas and
then get into specifics and what it
really showed or what they tried to say
that it showed is that you know people
who drink more diet coke are more likely
to have an increased risk of stroke
specifically and it kind of made the
media circles you know that people
shouldn't drink diet soda because it has
this increased risk of you know some bad
outcome that's related to cardiovascular
right so whenever you see a headline of
like a big health outcome you know
that's typically what gets people
interested and intrigued is if I can
find one thing that shows you something
bad had happened to you
you know then it's worth reading so that
was kind of the and it's also anything
that thing going for it where it's like
I mean it's it's a story as old as time
right like is that household item
actually killing you you know like I
mean artificial sweeteners these days
are everywhere so it was kind of like a
perfect storm to get the media you know
a little bit riled up yeah it's like I'm
sure whenever you've read any article on
CNN or science alert or ESPN there's
always like the paid content at the
bottom and it's always this one food you
know that cardiologists tell you
never eat again it's very much one of
those kind of click baby titles so yeah
I mean that's the the interesting thing
is those are always going to come up and
so you always have to find a way to dig
through that and then kind of come up
with what is actually being said from
that data yeah so so after you kind of
took a look at it without you know
you'll have to get into super granular
details but was there any meat behind
that was there justification to those
kind of scary headlines that came out
with it
yeah well the really interesting thing
that I liked about this article was that
it highlights one of the what I call
bigger issues of what we kind of see in
nutritional epidemiology studies is and
I'll talk about this first is this idea
that risk factors you know cluster and
the fact that it's really hard
statistically to tease out one thing
from all these other things so for
example you know in this study basically
what they showed was that if they took
people who had the highest amount of you
know diet soda intake per day which is
basically you know more than to
artificially sweetened beverages or like
diet sodas per week compared to you know
people who had less than one or never is
those people were almost twice as likely
to be smokers they you know had were
much more likely to be obese so a BMI of
over thirty they were more likely to be
hypertensive they were more than four
times more likely to have diabetes they
had a 30% higher rate of you know
previous cardiovascular issues they were
more likely to consume sugar sweetened
beverages on top of diet soda there were
a lot less active they had a lower
healthy eating index and they consumed
about 160 more calories a day so what's
really telling you is that you know all
of these other factors are also
associated with risk of stroke right so
we do know those from other independent
studies so it's first of all it's pretty
likely that they you know don't just
have the just the diet soda they have
all these other things you know that are
going on right
so did the authors of the study say like
you know we saw that they also had all
these other risk factors did they try to
account for them statistically or did
they just say just so you know these are
other things about diet soda drinkers
yeah so typically what they do is they
try to account for those statistically
right so they'll do kind of these
multi-step models and see which ones are
there but the problem is is even when
you statistically control for all those
things it doesn't you know it doesn't
really account for all of the biology
rain it doesn't account for all the
synergistic effects so you kind of run
into this thing of you can you can
adjust for all these you know
co-variants so to speak and still have
an independent risk that pops out but
that doesn't negate you know all the
other pieces that go into it so there's
kind of this statistical piece versus
this you know what actually is
meaningful right so so that's the big
thing to really understand there yeah I
think a lot of times we see this idea of
using these covariates and models and
saying oh well we accounted for that and
it's like well no you you tried to kind
of massage out that variability but but
I think a lot of times we kind of
overstate our confidence and how well
that statistical control is truly
getting to the root of that yeah and
what I would say is you know for people
who've ever done analyses like that is
you know you can really see how much
things change when you add subtract
different variables you you know kind of
transform data all that kind of stuff
really does matter in terms of you know
what your outcome is right so if you had
redone that model and included one
different variable depending on how
sensitive it was you know that finding
could have just washed away so so after
kind of reviewing the the paper as a
whole was your main takeaway that
essentially you had maybe not a lot of
confidence in the idea that the diet
soda was really dictating that stroke
risk yeah absolutely and then when you
kind of even when you you know accounted
for this whole you know health factors
cluster anything
is when you dive into the you know the
actual like rates of events and not just
basically of survival analysis and you
look at actual rates of events is there
was no difference so it didn't really
pan out all the way through what it
really looked like is they took a bunch
of data one of these large data sets and
they found something that popped out of
the data set which whenever you have
really large
you know sample sizes you're going to
find statistically significant things
I'm just that's the nature of of how the
math works you'll find something and
then you can publish it but when you
looked at the the actual incidence rates
is there was no difference between
people who had a lot and people who had
a little like for example I just pulled
it up real quick is you know first
stroke let's say all stroke which was
kind of their primary outcome as those
who had you know more than two a day was
about 2.5 incidents per thousand person
years and then people who had less than
one or never were 2.45 so it was
basically no difference in terms of what
that looks like it was that particular
comparison was that statistically
significant no so they were all
overlapping yeah okay yeah I'm gonna say
that must have been a 70 million person
trial yes we did that trial it didn't
even know it
okay so you bring up some good points
you know with first of all with the
covariance but also sometimes you know
even when we do look at EPI papers like
that I think this happens a lot in
nutrition epi sometimes you even will
find a statistically significant finding
but when you actually boil it down into
the things that that matter kind of the
tangible outcomes you'll say like oh so
instead of having a two percent risk of
getting that I'll have a two and a half
percent risk of getting that and in some
designs that will be you know a
statistically significant difference but
the take-home point is you're probably
not gonna have that issue yeah exactly
right so then I mean that's the argument
of absolute versus relative risk and
yeah you know whenever you read a lot of
these papers that have things like
survival analyses those are typically
all relative risks right you know and so
it's an odds or a change based on a
reference point but it doesn't tell you
about the absolute incidence and that's
why you can have to look at those and
see is this something that I want to
concern myself with it's kind of like
with a weight loss trial right you'll
say like oh these two you know we had a
control group and then this huge pain in
the ass intervention and after a year
the pain-in-the-ass intervention you
know you lost an extra kilogram and
you're like yeah yeah but it was a huge
pain in the ass like for a kilogram over
a year I just don't think I care and
there's no stats that can make me care
yeah and you know that's um that's kind
of one of the more interesting pieces
that this might this may go into tangent
but I was talking about this in a
lecture I was recording this morning is
one of the problems I think a lot of
people are running into a lot you know
with especially these like diet
intervention studies and we talk
specifically about like health outcomes
whether it's cancer risk cardiovascular
risk all those things is at this point a
lot of the interventions we have are on
top of what's current standard of care
and I think that's an important thing
for people to note especially when
they're looking at studies now versus
like the 1980s or 90s so if we look at
like let's say a like a diet study right
they want to look at food quality or
whatever for cardiovascular disease
outcomes if you were to do that study in
the 1980s right when standard of care
for cardiovascular disease was not
really well founded right there was not
like you know if you had blood sugar
issues who were immediately on metformin
if you had elevated cholesterol you're
immediately on a statin if you have
elevated triglycerides you're on you
know a phenyl fibrate etc which all you
know lower cardiovascular risk you know
if you put a dietary therapy on top of
that you're probably gonna see a pretty
big reduction in risk right because
there's no risk reduction occurring at
all but now that people are on all these
medications if you add you know a
dietary intervention that doesn't lead
to super substantial weight loss you
know you're not going to see a whole lot
of reduction in terms of risk for
cardiovascular outcomes
and I don't think a lot of people you
know really think about that in terms of
okay what is the context in which we're
actually looking for an effect all these
statistical tests are in most cases
against a comparator but what are you
comparing to basically like like what is
the context in which that intervention
is introduced and what is it compared to
exactly right so if we think about um
you know just a really real relevant
example like new drug trials for looking
at glycemic control right because I
spent most of my PhD and postdoc
fellowship doing diabetes work is like
if you were to look at almost any drug
in the nineteen late 1990s for improving
glycemic control like almost all of them
would have worked and shown you a
benefit right and been like above you
know what's current standard of care and
now we have you know we have kind of
polypharmacy that's all controlling this
stuff so any new drug you're gonna use
has to be better than you know what's
already pretty good and it has to be
know measurably better so it's it's just
such a different landscape when we look
at interventions and this is why I stay
the hell away from epi I did one happy
man the stuffs complicated how me I I
want to be a control freak so I don't
have to deal with all this crap I
control everything yeah so one final
thing to bring up did they put forth any
kind of viable in your opinion like a
viable justifiable mechanism by which
you would link the you know the
sweeteners to stroke risk no I mean I
can't even remember from the discussion
section if there was anything that was
even remotely close to being you know a
probable mechanism I think that's one of
the hard parts with these large epi
studies and things like artificial
sweeteners is when you don't have a
super clear mechanism you know anything
you can offer in a discussion section
has to be you know really well validated
I mean I think you know a good example
of that would be you know how did we go
from smoking epidemiology to
you know cessation of smoking reducing
lung cancer risk well we had big epi
data then we had a boatload of you know
very well controlled mechanistic studies
that supported that epi finding and with
the kind of artificial sweetener and
stroke risk
we have almost nothing so you're kind of
you only have one side of the coin yeah
so at the end of the day I mean I think
you and I are similar in the sense that
we like the science but the science is a
tool to actually move toward informing
behavior so at the end of the day do you
see any reason why why someone would
want to either avoid or restrict their
artificial sweetener use you know I
think there's that's where it comes down
to like individual you know responses
individual preferences etc you know
things like some people just report they
have headaches consuming diet soda right
whether the science bears that out I
think is still relatively unknown but
like if you don't feel good when you
drink diet soda
don't drink diet soda right you don't
you're not forced to drink it for any
health purposes that's a big take don't
do things that give you yeah you know so
it's a lot of it's you know things like
that or if you know you find you know
diet soda is a trigger for consuming a
bunch of other food you know think about
that in the context of those things so
it's always I kind of view Sciences how
can I use this to empower my
decision-making and you know if I can
look at if I can look at all the
evidence to say okay diet soda doesn't
have any large negative health
consequences that gives me this one
thing I can use it might in my toolkit
right buy of somebody who's drinking a
boatload of you know real soda and
they're getting a thousand calories a
day from coca-cola if I can switch them
to Diet Coke that's probably in that
benefit identify exactly not even I mean
that thousand calorie number is not a
particularly unrealistic number you know
the certain demographics I have a buddy
who's a dietitian
and you know and he'll have clients that
honest-to-god thousand calories of soda
and so like you know whenever these bad
papers come out with with artificial
sweeteners he's like okay but like when
you've got somebody who's like close to
losing a limb to diabetes and you can
knock a thousand calories worth of sugar
out of their diet you do it yeah exactly
right so it's I always view these kind
of things as like what can I learn that
adds a tool to my toolbox yeah or if you
have a bodybuilder who it's the only
thing that makes them kind of happy is
there one diet soda for the day what
kind of a monster would take that from
them but I mean you know I've looked at
the artificial sweetener stuff and
correct me if I'm wrong but when it
comes to weight management it seems to
be pretty neutral you know the biggest
thing I've seen lately with them is
people talking about how they affect the
the gut microbiome and that seems to me
not not fully conclusive at this time is
that how you perceive it yeah I would
say I would say one that date is pretty
inconclusive at this point from from my
read of the literature um to microbiome
stuff yeah yeah and then to I would say
I just think our understanding of the
microbiome in general is not well
understood I think we're far from
understanding you know how certain
things perturb the microbiome and then
how that affects you know obesity
cardiovascular risk stroke cancer all
that stuff I think it's I just think we
have no real comprehensive understanding
of that at this point yeah I used to get
a kick out of it because especially some
of the early papers in that area and
these are very good scientists doing I'm
not being you know hyper critical but in
many cases they would report you know
some kind of thing and say well the
microbiome changed yeah maybe it should
think yeah and it's like in a good way
or a bad way like well in a different
way he's like and that you know you
would have to kind of run with it and
make some kind of working conclusion of
what you found but we really we really
are
at the beginning of figuring out not
just what induced changes but where the
ramifications of those changes and the
change is not always bad you know yeah
and I almost like I start to like in
microbiome research too you know
neurobiology in the fact that you have a
very complicated system that's highly
networked that has a lot of downstream
effects you need really powerful
computation to start to even tease those
relationships out and then understanding
the causal nature of those I mean it's
gonna take a long time to unravel that
you know if you think about it the whole
you know bacterial interaction with
other organisms is billions of years old
so the fact that we have not unlocked
all the keys and I think it's been maybe
12 15 years of research does not
surprise me whatsoever
so you're saying five more years I'm
saying five more years we might have a
start of a picture that's Brad with his
classic his classic optimism now there
was another paper that made a lot of
headlines recently so Kevan Hall is he's
a beast
Kevan halls like the lead researcher at
the NIH basically all their dietary
interventions their nutrition
interventions and he finally did a study
looking at processed food intake in a
highly controlled environment do you
mind givin just like a brief overview of
what what he was comparing there yeah so
what he was really starting to look at
was you know if you take people and you
give them ultra-processed foods versus
unprocessed foods what happens to their
calorie intake over that period of time
right and you don't really restrict them
on what they could eat he wanted to see
basically how does you know the
palatability or the process nature of
your food affect your food intake and he
wanted to do that with as much control
as possible so we you know he did things
where he controlled protein intake as
much as he could across the groups like
he made the protein density of the food
as close as possible obviously energy
density was a little bit different but
he tried to make it as well controlled
as possible
and wanted to see you know if I give
people a diet of unprocessed food versus
processed food does it change how much
food they consume and it was kind of a
an experiment that wanted to look at how
is the modern food environment changed
our you know our food consumption
behavior and could part of it be you
know just due to the process nature of
the food right we've had a lot of like
oh this must be it but this is one of
the first really good experiments that
actually tested that and quantify that
effect what did they find
so basically what he found you know with
all the details spared is that people
who are given a processed diet consumed
about 500 calories a day more which is
you know about 3500 calories a week yeah
now what the major finding that's a
significant amount of calories that is
that is the significant amount of
calories and I think one of the most
interesting pieces to this was that we
kind of have you know human biology kind
of has this thing built in where we can
kind of regulate our food intake you
know in a normal ish food environment
but what he found was that you know
something about the processed foods
versus the unprocessed foods they have
the same effect on kind of pleasantness
fullness satisfaction so even though
these people were consuming you know 500
calories a day more or 3500 calories a
week more which is a large surplus
there's no difference in kind of
perception of fullness enjoyment of food
etc which is you know something that's
very interesting because it starts to
kind of tip our hat towards something
about these this combination of really
ultra processed food kind of overrides
some of our biological mechanisms to
control you know food intake at least
over this short term period do you think
palatability is is kind of one of the
main driving factors do you think it's
more than that you know I think there's
I think palatability is part of it I
think that has to deal with part of the
you know satisfaction of eating food
right I think when you eat bland food
versus hyper palatable food you know
suppose
you you enjoy the hyper palatable food
more I think there's some data from that
paper to suggest there's some hormonal
piece to it too so it may go beyond you
know just the processed
tasteful nature of the food so it's you
know that's probably multifactorial of
what's going on so there's there's
probably this you know brain reward
piece there's probably a hormonal piece
there's probably just a behavioral piece
but it's it's starting to show that
there's something about this food that's
kind of driving over consumption yeah I
mean I know the idea that you know
especially in like the bodybuilding
world the fitness world there's the
whole you know if it fits your macros
nothing else matters and I think it's
very safe to say that that is a gross
oversimplification we know that that
food affects more than that I know the
the Kevin hall study was to look at how
eating behavior would be affected so
they were not calorie controlled but
even you know when people are on a
really really low calorie diet
some people go the direction where they
try to make their their foods they go
with very processed hyper palatable food
combinations and they spend a lot of
effort and time making those on low
macros and sometimes I advise against
that
you know it depends on the person but
like for me that just makes the process
worse that have you ever like messed
around with that when you're dieting or
with clients yeah you know I would say
you know first I totally agree with you
that you know calorie balance is one
idea but to suggest that the types of
food you consume doesn't matter is is a
really gross representation of this idea
of calorie balance and it's it's
absolutely true that we know that you
know as caloric intake goes down the
types of food you eat to kind of manage
hunger does start to matter a lot more I
think there's some good data from the
literature to suggest that's true I
think we know you know what types of
foods on average are more satiating than
others typically kind of more
unprocessed foods tend to be more
satiating that others obviously there's
exceptions you know things like you know
like olive oil or butter which are
minimally processed you know a pretty
energy dense compared to other things
but I think in general you know managing
hunger and very low levels of calorie
intake does start to become this like
what is it about your food outside the
calories that we can play with you and
there's a lot of different things that
affect that yeah and by the way
rethinking my statement certainly that
the macros are what make the the big
time changes so I'm certainly not
disputing that but there are aspects of
food that the go beyond the macros that
offer us tools to affect the diet and
how we respond to it
but I think one of the cool things about
Kevin Hall's paper is that it kind of
there's been this question for several
years now why in the past few decades
have we been getting fatter you know
when you look at the just the prevalence
of overweight and obesity all the maps
that used to be that you know those
pretty light yellow colors are now dark
red we see these rates going up across
the board in the United States do you
think processed foods play a big role in
that yeah I think they I think it would
be hard to argue that they do not I
think most of the evidence suggests that
it plays one role or its plays a role
amongst the many factors that have
driven this issue so I think processed
foods are one of them I think in certain
cultures it's a bigger factor than
others you know I think one of the
things that we've most people have kind
of missed the boat on is the fact that
there's kind of regional hotspots of
obesity kind of tells you that we know
that kind of obesity in general is a
multifactorial issue right and that we
have I don't know 20 inputs that cause
that and each kind of hot spot or area
likely has you know different knobs that
really turn that you know increase in
obesity up right so we some areas it's
just lack of physical activity and
that's more prevalent than others some
it may be
food access that's different you know
others that may just be cultural some it
may be a tiny bit more genetic you know
some it may be et cetera so I think part
of the problem we've had is we don't
recognize that while obesity has very
common root causes the amount to which
each root cause contributes can vary
based on the situation
yeah and so recently on the on the Joe
Rogan podcast which I consider to be a
peer podcast you know when you think
popular podcast you think stronger by
science or Joe Rogan um absolutely right
there was a debate between Gary Talib's
and Stephan DNA is that hoisin yeah yeah
DNA so um who okay well you didn't call
him Steve so you're already one up on
Gary yeah so you saw the debate right
yeah yeah what was your main takeaway
how do you think it went yeah it was man
it was so interesting I did a little bit
of a write-up on this but it was almost
Oh before I forget the reason I'm
linking the two together basically the
premise of the debate was why did we get
obese and how much of a role does
carbohydrate or insulin play in that
yeah so that was yeah so the debate was
the way I viewed it was you kind of had
two people who speak very different
languages and have very different views
of the world trying to come to a common
answer um you know I think I think
Stephan is probably one of the smartest
people in terms of anybody in the world
who understands causes of obesity you
know I think Gary is a very good
journalist and storyteller who has he's
kind of a what I would call a tsiyon a
scientism perspective not a scientific
perspective and the fact that he kind of
uses it as a buzzword but doesn't really
fully understand all of its pieces and
mechanisms and so Stephan very much came
from a here's the data
here is the best interpretation we have
based on that data and Gary's approaches
very much here's some stories that
really kind of resonate with people and
here's the story I think to be true and
here's a few pieces of data that might
support it and that was really kind of
two very different approaches to the
problem and so I think that was that was
really interesting just to kind of watch
that happen just kind of in real life
play out so as rush limbaugh would say
Gary Taubes is part of the drive-by
media that is using his journalistic
wisdom to kind of take bits and pieces
to put a story together yeah I would say
that's that's pretty accurate
it was also very clear that he he had
this view of almost a contempt for
science and how it's done I think there
was there was a comment I can't remember
exactly what it was but he said
something about how meta analyses take
all these garbage studies and put them
together and then publish the results
without looking at the quality of the
studies and I was like that's literally
not how it's done at all right if you've
ever read a Cochrane review if you've
ever read you know one of the big meta
analyses they publish with the meta
analyses their inclusion criteria their
exclusion criteria biases they do that
they do statistical tests for looking at
you know publication bias they will rate
studies in their quality but what you
know if any we're excluded due to
quality issues so it's like there was a
lot of that stuff that was said that's
just very not true of how the process of
science is actually conducted watching
the the podcast was fascinating because
you can tell that Gary is a damn good
journalist because for every even for
some studies he would say no but what's
the real story behind the story so it
was not what did the data say but how
were the data how did this study come to
be so not methodology but what was the
funding relationship and what was maybe
the intrinsic bias of the researcher
going into it and and what were the
educational backgrounds that might
person in
influence the way they interpreted their
own data you could see these two
different worlds like you mentioned yeah
and I've never really upset that by the
way that you didn't laugh at my rush
limbaugh thing Greg challenged me this
morning to see if I could work in a Rush
Limbaugh reference at some point in the
podcast there you go today it worked and
I thought that was I thought it was
actually relevant I think my problem is
whenever I hear like a like Fox News or
CNN like person's name mentioned I just
like I get this black hole in my brain
and I just can't drop it anything that
happens yeah but was you know what's
interesting that you bring up is you
know Gary made a very interesting
comment several times throughout the PAR
the the debate of you know scientists
bring this very siloed perspective you
know he'd mentioned that Stefan you know
only thought about the neurobiology
piece because that's what he did is his
research in and that right there kind of
showed me a big big hole in his
understanding of exactly like as a
scientist what you do and how your
career unfolds and the fact that just
because you have one specific focus
doesn't mean you don't think about all
the other pieces that are related to it
right
I mean Stefan did a he did his PhD in
neurobiology he did a fellowship I know
he did at least one fellowship he minded
them too looking at the neurobiology of
obesity and in his lab and right down
the hall cuz I know where his lab we
used to be excited to go over there all
the time you know where people who are
doing you know overall metabolism
research other diabetes research that
are not in the brain you know they're
working on peripheral mechanisms they're
working on all this other stuff but just
because you only have the capacity to do
so much work in a career you focus on
one piece it's very similar to how you
know Gary is a you know quote unquote
science journalist right he doesn't
cover like women's fashion right I mean
should we say that he is not a good
journalist and that journalism has a big
flaw because you know what journalists
only focuses on one area it's like well
you you have to carve out your area of
expertise and you know just because of
that that doesn't mean Gary doesn't
understand how journalism works
it's just that's your content area of
focus yeah there was a couple times
where he mentioned that people went in
the weight regulation space got got way
away from anything happening in the
periphery of the body and that's just
not been my experience working through
the literature you know what I mean like
that that's not at all what I see so
yeah I don't know aside from being a
compelling narrative I'm not really sure
where that came from I mean is that has
that been your experience I think that's
it's a really good it's a really good
trope to use to cast doubt on somebody
and I think it's it's very effective
right if I say well all you do is think
about the brain and I can say you did
all of your research in the brain you
know people are gonna be like oh yeah
that's he hasn't thought about anything
else so it's kind of an easy sticking
point to just put a pin in for somebody
but as a general rule you know just
because you are primarily focused on one
aspect of science doesn't mean you don't
understand the rest of it right like I
spent most of my career studying you
know diabetes and end-organ
complications but that doesn't mean I
don't understand how you know insulin
kinetics and that tissue work right like
that's part of my fundamental
understanding of human biology that you
have to use on a day-to-day basis now
one of the things that and by the way I
thought the debate was really good I
thought it was it was interesting to see
very different approaches and to see how
the general population responds to each
one of the things that kind of came up
kind of an overarching theme of the
debate is basically the regulation of
body weight and you wrote a really good
article I don't know when you wrote it
but I just saw it again today about body
fat set points or at least settling
points and I was reading it and I was
like wow this is really good I can't
believe I've never seen this article and
then at the bottom of it you you
mentioned that you and I had talked
while you were writing it and then I had
sent you a reference I was like oh yeah
you don't know the gravitas that paper
you sent me why I remember it now I was
like damn this is a good paper that the
end
like hey thanks to Eric for chatting
with me I was like what the hell is like
it's been a long couple years man but um
do you mind kind of explaining the
premise of you know cuz it ties in with
body weight regulation and obesity what
exactly is a body fat setpoint yeah so
there's kind of this idea of your body
weight and your body fat we can kind of
view them for the moment is one thing
and we'll kind of break them apart later
is that your body has mechanisms that
kind of control both of those right try
to keep them even right it's kind of
like probably the best way I can think
about it in at the moment off the top of
my head is think about your your body
height right like you grow to a certain
height I prefer not to Brad um you know
what I mean I'm very pleased channelized
okay let's say uh yeah we can use it or
use it anyway um right so like there's
some biological mechanism that tells
your body to grow and then there's a
biological mechanism that says okay this
is a good height for us let's just stop
growing right right and if you kind of
use that idea you have that in all sorts
of other mechanisms right you have it
with blood pressure right there's
mechanisms that regulate blood pressure
up and down heart rate pretty much
everything has this kind of homeostatic
basis that you can shift up or you can
shift down but for the most part you
kind of have this stable level and so
there's been this idea that your body
weight is kind of the same thing now if
you kind of look through all of the
literature on all just summarize this as
easily as I can is our body very clearly
has mechanisms that defend against
changes in body fat right up or down
right let's say you're set body fat is
10% you have mechanisms that will try to
keep it at 10% you know whether it goes
up to 12
it'll be things that are kind of push it
back down to 10 if it goes down to 8
there'll be things that push it back up
to 10 and there's a lot of different
things that are going on right there's
things like leptin there's just a whole
lot of different things that go on and
that's been tested very very very
rigorous
and we see this a lot in dieting trials
we see this a lot in medication trials
and we know that that's there so that's
one piece of evidence or one you know
one aspect to this problem now the other
aspect to this is we know that this
mechanism can't be incredibly powerful
because otherwise we wouldn't have the
obesity problem we have right yeah I
mean if it's tightly regulated then you
want to be gaining a ton of weight right
you you would start gaining and the body
would correct it yeah so I think one of
the things that's happened is people
have said okay well if you know if all
these people are gaining excess amounts
of body fat and I'm not saying it
there's that point we we don't have a
you know mechanisms that defend us that
way well I think that's you know
probably not the right way to think
about it and really what it is is we
have these biological mechanisms that
defend against changes in body weight
and body fat but those can be
overpowered right and either it's the
magnitude of the stimulus or it's the
length of the stimulus or it's some
combination of both right so for example
if you overeat by 50 calories a day you
know your body can probably handle that
extra for a long time and your body will
stay the same on the other hand if you
you know consume 25,000 calories in a
day your body probably can't handle all
that and there's going to be some
storage of body fat yeah and what we're
really starting to see is the truth of
why we can't defend against this kind of
moderately lean set point is we have a
relatively large stimulus right where if
we look at physical activity and food
intake data looks to be somewhere in the
neighborhood of 200 to 400 calories 500
calories a day depending on where you
look over decades right so you kind of
have this magnitude and this length
problem that's kind of surpassing our
adaptive mechanisms and that's kind of
really you know where we kind of leave
it is it's clear we have these adaptive
mechanisms there's enough data to
suggest that's very true but they're
clearly not strong enough to kind of
overcome
all these environmental stimuli that are
kind of overpowering our ability to
maintain setpoint yeah and I mean that's
pretty pretty clear especially looking
at that side of the equation you know
can you override the mechanisms that
keep your bodyweight low absolutely and
most people do you know mathematically
now the question that I've always been
interested in you know I've done some
work with you know metabolic adaptations
to weight loss that are the other side
when we try to lose weight things that
are there to slow us down
my question is when we when we talk
about these mechanisms to defend body
weight what do we do for someone who has
to lose a substantial amount of body fat
they're stable at a very high body
weight and they want to lose the weight
and keep it off do you think we have the
capacity to essentially reset our new
point that we're gonna settle at in
terms of body fat um I would say I don't
know the answer to that question and I
think it's because there's a lot of
there's a lot of stuff in the literature
that suggests that you know always lean
versus you know once obese are very
different and so I think there's there
is something that happens when somebody
becomes you know substantially obese you
know whether it's a BMI of 35 40 45 if
there's a hard cutoff we don't know but
there is something that occurs that
makes it difficult to lose all that
weight and keep it off exactly what that
is I don't have the exact answer to I
think there's some change in you know
whether it's kind of the neurobiology of
a setpoint whether it's the hormonal
piece of a setpoint there's a lot of
stuff out there that's kind of pointing
to different things and it appears to be
multifactorial I think there's some
neurobiology component I think there's
some hormonal component for example we
do know
that people who gain a lot of weight and
then lose it their leptin signaling is
different than people who are always
lean right so they they show some sort
of sustained leptin resistance things
like insulin resistance which do impact
overall metabolism you know is different
in people who were obese and then go
back to being lean versus somebody who's
always been lean so I think there's
there are changes that occur on that
that can affect this kind of long-term
ability to sustain massive weight loss
so I think that's that's a piece of it
and I think there's probably also it's
pretty clear that there's some
behavioral component right it is people
who have you know ended up at 350 or 400
pounds there's some behavioral component
that maybe it's fixed and then you know
just not fixed long term I think that's
a component of it too so I think it's
multifactorial yeah the only thing I
took away from that is that you
mentioned insulin so it sounds like
you're a table guy you're saying it
sounds like influenza cailli all we have
going on yeah interesting take that's
the rush limbaugh interpretation of what
I just said sometimes I kind of take
what I what makes me feel good and I
leave the rest so I think you bring up a
great point so like you're gonna talk
about metabolic adaptation at Inland
Empire fitness conference I can't wait
to hear what you have to say about it
because I've been talking about it for
ages and it's tricky because you know
because I've been I've worked in that I
tend to focus on the adaptations that
persist you know physiology looking at
hormones looking at energy expenditure
and the two areas that I probably
haven't looked
I haven't stressed enough looking at my
own kind of interpretation is the
neurobiology because it's it's hard to
really suss out exactly what's going on
but also one thing that gets overlooked
is the environment people had habits in
place for many years that at least
allowed for that
excess adiposity and it's behaviors of
activity level its behaviors of
structured exercise and non-exercise
activity its behaviors of eating and how
you view food you know I mean I almost
didn't realize how much food meant for
social interaction until I started
wrestling and you realize that during
the wrestling season you basically can't
celebrate a damn thing because
everything in you know at least in in
the environment I grew up in every major
event that you wish to celebrate there's
some kind of food or drink component yep
and yeah we look at like why do people
struggle with with weight loss it's not
hard to start finding reasons why the
cards are kind of stacked against you of
course you want to revert back to your
typical behaviors they were your typical
behaviors for a reason you're wired to
do those and it's how it's how you're
used to to doing things there's the
energy expenditure stuff there's the
neurobiology there's so much there so
I'm really looking forward to to your
talk on that in in Spokane are you gonna
get into some of the neurobiology and
behavioral stuff I think I'm gonna
primarily focus on more of kind of like
the what's interventional piece you know
I think yeah whatever whenever I give
talks to broad audiences as I try to
make it as actionable as possible and I
think a lot of the a lot of the
neurobiology stuff is just not super
actionable I do think it I think it
regulates a lot of what goes on and I
think there's strong data to support
that my only fear about spending a lot
of time talking about that is it's super
interesting but most people can't do
anything with it yeah what that's gonna
look like is you talkin me smiling very
wide and everyone else is sleep and just
like why did we invite Brad yeah that's
pretty much it but you know what's
interesting too is while we're on this
topic and something that I've been
thinking about for a while is I think a
lot of times we have this view of kind
of you know metabolism metabolic
adaptation or whatever of like these the
set long
Changez right is it's like oh I've done
this and now my metabolisms this and I
start to think about it more as like
you're a living breathing biological
organism that responds to everything all
the time
and if you start to think about your
your quote-unquote metabolism as this
kind of always shifting landscape it
starts to help you really understand
what's going on better right so instead
of thinking about it as this thing and
then I diet and then it goes to this
other thing is if you think about it
like it should always be adapting to
what I'm doing
so if I think about it that way I'm kind
of always on this landscape of change
and you're just trying to figure out
where you are and I think if you start
thinking about it that way it's a lot
more helpful for people yeah you don't
want to dichotomize it into my
metabolism was good and now it's not you
know it's it's a spectrum that you're
kind of existing within and I think
you're right that the more that we help
people understand what's happening even
if it's not really nitty-gritty science
just having an understanding of what's
happening what what you can expect I
think that puts a lot of people's mind
at ease and really helps people
accomplish their goals in a it's just a
less stress inducing less scary way to
do things when you have some expectation
yeah I think I think the other piece is
just people knowing that they're not
abnormal yeah definitely nobody wants to
be abnormal yeah unless you want to be
the abnormal billionaire or something
and then if member wouldn't be a bad
thing yeah I I could live with that
but yeah I participated in a study this
morning that was exercise related there
was exercise testing and they're like
what are you shooting for and I said my
only goal is to not be an outlier it was
an endurance related task and endurance
is not my thing so as a person who hates
endurance and love statistics my only
goal was to not completely distort their
data set I bet you're the first person
to respond with that
probably yeah what's your goal to make
the the bell curve as beautiful and
bell-shaped as possible but I want to be
on the higher tail because somebody has
to be out there and I want it to be me
listen Brad it wasn't gonna be me not
today no not with this task well I tell
you what Brad one of the things I really
like about you and the work you do is
that you could exist in a space well
above our heads you know what I mean you
have the intellectual horse drive and
the skill set that if you were in this
just to make yourself sound smart you
could do that and it'd be great for your
ego probably but the way that you convey
information is so helpful it's humble
and it really is it's for the people
reading it and listening to it I love
how you can take these complex ideas
boil them down and package them in a
really accessible way so hopefully
people will come out to the Inland
Empire fitness conference in Spokane
this might not be up by the time it
happens but catch it next year but but
if people want to follow you and kind of
keep up to date with what you're putting
out in different projects you're
involved with how can I get in touch
with you yeah well thanks for the kind
words Eric that's that's probably more
than I deserve so I'll say thank you for
that
and yeah probably the best place to find
me um you can find me on Facebook you
can find me on Instagram just look up my
name I think there may be only one other
Brad dieter in the entire universe
and if I ever find him we'll take a
selfie together but I'm probably the
only person that's on social media
really that you can find so just look me
up there you can find me at each perform
that's where all of our kind of coaching
software technology business lives I
have my personal blog which is science
driven nutrition a new article will be
released there right after the Inland
Empire fitness conference and yeah
that's that's probably the best way to
find me
one thing I like to ask people now you
you're you're an evidence-based guy for
whatever that means
but you know you you you're in touch
with the science but you also you
exercise yourself you train clients you
help clients with dieting I presume is
there a thing you do in your own
practice or working with clients that
kind of flies in the face of the current
evidence-based consensus or are there
any things that you do that maybe you
believe in them very strongly but
there's not really evidence to support
them yet huh that's a good question you
know I can't think of anything off the
top of my head I think part of my thing
is I don't do anything extremely radical
mm-hmm so like I've always kind of been
the person who's focused on consistency
over a long period of time um and I've
never seen anything that's been so crazy
that I feel like I have to do or test or
try so I think that's that's maybe part
of my one of my shortcomings is I'm not
like a huge take giant leaps of faith
into weird things that are unknown like
grounding or supplements or weird
workouts or anything like that so I
don't think there's anything I mean I
probably drink way too much coffee and
do not sleep at all so that I would say
that's what I do that's incongruent with
what the world tells me I should be
doing but I don't have any like super
weird weird things how much coffee is
too much coffee um that's an undisclosed
answer somewhere in the neighborhood of
like two pots a day probably like a like
a 12 cup pot more like two eight cup
pots probably okay cuz Greg was giving
me the rundown of his stimulant
situation the other day and it was it
was sobering I was data collection mode
so he's in data collection mode and
running to businesses and yeah he he
basically told me the amount of
stimulants to get him out of bed and
like by the time I cut him
and said I've heard enough we weren't
even at the office yet it's bad so I'm
with you I mean when they came out and
they're like once it started becoming
clear you could get um genetic testing
very excessively to figure out if you're
a fast or slow caffeine metabolizer Greg
and I are both of the opinion we just
don't care you know there's nothing you
can tell me about my genome or my
physiology that's gonna get between me
and caffeine so and see my wife thoughts
on that somebody asked me if I was gonna
get it done and I'm like well here's the
two outcomes either one it's gonna tell
me that I should not drink a lot of
caffeine and I'm gonna continue doing it
and I'm gonna be paranoid about it or
two it's gonna tell me I can drink a lot
of caffeine and I'm gonna double what's
already a no abhorrent dose so it's kind
of a lose-lose situation for my overall
health so I'm just gonna be like I just
don't need to know yeah
well I'm hoping that we'll be able to
maybe get a cup of coffee in Spokane in
a few weeks and catch up but thank you
so much for for coming on the podcast
today a lot of great information if
you're listening go check out Brad's
websites go check out a social media he
puts out great content all the time the
stuff I asked him about today it was
just stuff he was rambling about on
Facebook so if you want to actually make
your social media time useful get in
touch with Brad follow Brad and keep an
eye on on what he's doing that is it for
today's episode we will see you guys
next time thanks for listening to the
stronger by science podcast now Greg and
I are not experts in medicine or health
or really anything else for that matter
so before you make any changes to your
diet and exercise habits make sure you
check with a doctor or another health
care professional if you enjoyed this
podcast and you'd like to support it
visit stronger by science com to check
out the products and services that we
offer thanks for listening and we'll see
you next time
[Music]
you
you